Philadelphia city of brotherly love and
home to a very different kind of
fellowship tonight
Philadelphia's hosting one of the
country's biggest vampire events sales
clerk Jen Hoffman has traveled from
Delaware to attend Dracula's ball for
her the event offers excitement and a
chance to celebrate an identity many
would call tabooed jen says she's a
vampire and she drinks human blood
tonight she'll quench her thirst
Jen's friend Cheryl has agreed to let
Jim suck her blood but before the
feeding Jen and Cheryl will attend
Dracula's ball in addition to being a
vampire Jen's also a goth a person who
enjoys medieval fashion and fantasy with
costume corset wigs and makeup
the women transform themselves into
Gothic princesses long after the Sun has
set and darkness envelops the city
Dracula's ball is in full swing the
dance floor is crowded with Goths
vampires and everything indeed
many partygoers are self-proclaimed
vampire lifestyles people who embrace
the look if not the deed fake
erotic costumes and ghostly contact
lenses make clear these folks enjoyed
being different
no blood play is allowed in the club
with the energy at the ball wets Jen's
appetite it's time for her to dine on
blood Jen burns herbs to cleanse the
hotel room she'll use medical lancets to
draw Cheryl's blood it's been one month
since I fed so this for me is kind of a
good pivotal moment to hold me over till
the next round and yeah I'm a little
hungry with mounting excitement Jen
pricks
Cheryl's finger it's only a drop but the
first of many
in the age of AIDS few would take so
great a risk
however these blood drinkers are tested
regularly and are confident that they
are disease-free
ten minutes later as dawn breaks the
feeding ends I want more but there are
other days the vampire ball may be over
but jen has no plans to stop feeding on
blood any time soon